[Music]
hi i'm ronald akeley i'm the founder of
potato head
radical sustainability is part of
internet's dna
we believe it's easier for people to
adopt change when they don't really have
to compromise on beauty accessibility
and comfort
we have our own design lab which does
research and managing our ways from
recycling and upcycling so 90 of our
waste is currently managing house
we've created our amenities and interior
for the hotel room
with a lot of materials out of ways
candles that is made from used cooking
oil chairs that is made from single-use
plastic bottle caps
all the way to toiletries dispensers
that's made from
our love over styrofoams from our food
suppliers to oyster shells from our
restaurant our aim is to show our guests
how creativity and design could be a
powerful vehicle of change
we have been fortunate to work with
designers and creatives who hold the
same philosophy of design and
sustainability oma is really good at
designing public space
interacting with amazing cultural
programming and looking at design
approaches and
making it as sustainable as possible
we're working on the project with
kangaroo kumar building
our own farmhouse on the west side of
lobby
we've developed
a brick made out of plastic bags and
sand
max lab has an incredible ability
in integrating any materials we design
turning ways into beautiful products
we opened potato head in 2009 since then
we have seen
the impact uh bali has gotten from
tourism and waste
five years ago we've made a commitment
to be part of the solution rather than a
problem you might never reach that goal
of a zero-waste landfill what's
most important is that we're going to go
into that path
and last we also want to show that
sustainability should be beautiful
please come and join us and our friends
at singapore design week 2022.
[Music]